it is time to pause for menopause the
musical
the hilarious show has returned to
harrah's cabaret
inside harris for its 16th historic year
and we have earth mother herself from
the show vida karumi joining
us today 16 years vita that's a lot of
menopause
for those that have not seen us tell us
what to expect
well it's it's going to have you
laughing from the time you walk in
till the time you leave and you're going
to feel better when you left
because it's a sisterhood and the reason
we're the longest running
musical theater show in las vegas
history is because it's funny
it's relatable people feel like they're
a part of it
and i've been doing it the whole time
i'm the only original left i've been
doing it so long i'm finally in
menopause
now you tell us about your character who
is earth mother what is she all about
well my character um we none of the
characters have names they have
like an explanation so i'm earth mother
i'm kind of like a
a reject from the 60s you know i'm all
about
zen and spirit you know spirituality and
and releasing everything and letting it
go and the other three characters
are the power woman who runs the company
in the big city for the first time and
an aging soap star so
people women and even men can relate to
it on every level
the show is funny to begin with have you
ever had any on stage embarrassing
moments
oh my gosh of course what happened i
feared her anything could happen
um well i can tell you one that comes to
mind that was probably the most
embarrassing
moment was when my character has she's
she's
she just won a a workout session and
she's like
huffing and puffing and in a track suit
and as i bent over
you know kind of showing my derriere to
the audience there was a sound glitch
with this
ball and it was just perfect timing
right
when that happened i have heard nothing
but great things about it now tell
everyone when does the show run how can
they see it
well the show is at harrah's las vegas
and we have two shows on tuesdays four
and eight
two shows on saturdays four and eight
and monday wednesday thursday friday at
eight pm
and uh dark on sundays be prepared
to laugh it is the longest running
scripted musical in las vegas history
what do you say
16 more years after this oh heck yeah
it is delighted so many audiences thank
you so much for your time vida
and menopause the musical will perform
monday through
saturday at 8 pm with a 4 p.m matinee on
saturday and tuesday if you want your
tickets all you have to do
is go to menopausethemusical.com to
purchase them